hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday january 17th
[Applause]
i'm gonna have fun saying that this year
how are you
what's going on how was your goddamn
weekend
oh you know what i got i got a really
bad feeling
i got a really bad feeling you know what
that a bunch of buffalo bills fans i bet
my numbers are off the charts this week
for the buffalo bills fans all tuning in
they didn't tune in when we beat him in
the windy game i'm sure they all sat
that [ __ ] one out
um oh my god yeah well
i'll be honest with you i didn't think
we were going to win
but i didn't think that was going to
happen
we got our asses what
um
i mean i would love to say that that
what looked to be a touchdown pass by
mack jones and then one of the greatest
interceptions i've ever seen
that safety coming over the top
like [ __ ] john stalworth that catch
against the rams back in the [ __ ]
super bowl 1979 is what
that reminded me of and uh that if that
was a touchdown
you know does that change the tone of
the game i don't think so i don't think
so um
i don't know what happened to the bills
in the middle of the seasons where all
of a sudden they [ __ ] the bed but uh
in the beginning this season they look
like world beaters and then they look
like
they were gonna do what they always do
to their fans which is let them down
um and now they're back and they're
looking like world bds although you know
they beat a young patriots team with the
rookie quarterback and uh
you know i think mac jones and some of
those guys took too much criticism from
patriots fans where it's just like
you know we're starting over there's a
new guy
you know
um
look where we were last year i mean
jesus christ the whole the [ __ ]
wheels were off
and this year we almost won the division
and won the playoffs got our asks is
kicked and you know what that's a good
[ __ ] thing
it's a good thing because uh they'll
remember that and they'll build on it
and i'm just happy that like you know i
was worried that once you know
cam newton didn't work out brady's gone
that we were just gonna be basement
dwellers but the fact that we're where
we're at is [ __ ] great
um and i i had a [ __ ] blast like um
i sort of live tweeted the game
and as you watched it i mean the [ __ ]
thing was out of hand quick
so i just started like bitching about
the officiating like ridiculously
people just took the bait you couldn't
believe it there was one this i don't
even know what it made the score like 33
to [ __ ] three or something
and uh this [ __ ] guy in the bills he
must have had like five yards on the
defender
and you know they're just showing josh
allen you know
dropping back he throws the ball and you
just see this guy wide open and you know
so there's no way i could have seen the
corner or anything
and i tweeted out something like uh
did they ever call offensive pass
interference
ridiculous and [ __ ] these idiot fans
were jumping on not saying all but
bill's fancy idiot is because i could
have got patriots fans with that if it
went the other way if i was a bills fan
and we were beating them but uh i just
had a [ __ ] blast doing that and then
i was doing like the stupid you know
sports talk radio stuff like oh they're
taking their foot off the gas a little
too early
but i will say this
for as much as an ass kicking as it was
i did watch the whole game i didn't turn
it off like most fans
i can't watch dude can't watch this you
know
like the [ __ ] bills fans probably did
four super bowls in a row just turning
off the game um i'm really getting tired
of how much they glorify bill's fans
like there's not the same amount of
[ __ ]
in that [ __ ] just because they lose now
you feel bad for them
um oh that was another tweet i had of
them i go you know i really hope you
guys win it this year because i'm really
tired that half of the buffalo bills
highlights is about your fans tailgating
we're jumping on tables
um
anyway
if i was a doctor
uh that's i would open up a practice out
in buffalo if and i would i would
specialize in rebuilding shoulders
uh it's gonna be a lot of that
jesus christ uh but anyways it was just
an absolute ass kicking and i gotta tell
you you know um the kc and the steelers
is on right now it's starting to get a
little out of hand
but uh
i don't see anybody that the bills
couldn't beat
you know but
i gotta tell you
are you a little concerned about the
kicking game in buffalo
guy missed two extra points one of them
was tipped but whatever
one gets tipped and then he misses the
next one
all right
and you don't need to tell a patriots
fan or a bills fan how important the
kicking game is because we've been on
both sides of that coin we have a first
ballot hall of famer and adam vinatieri
and uh you guys had that other guy um
so we shall see we'll see if that comes
back i mean the guy's been great in the
regular season but that's the regular
season all of a sudden it's the playoffs
and it gets a little bit tighter and
these bills fans were all excited
because they finally beat bill belichick
and maybe they're forgetting
that there's a guy named tom brady out
there beat the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
eagles
right
bills fence you gotta want it you have
if you have any [ __ ] balls left
all right after landing on tables doing
splits or whatever the [ __ ] you guys
have been doing out there to distract
the fact that you have an absolutely
pathetic franchise for all of these
years
you have to want to play the tampa bay
buccaneers
so not only can you finally [ __ ] win
a super bowl
get that monkey off your back you
already beat belichick you have to want
tom brady
you got to want that game and i got to
tell you something if tom goes in there
and [ __ ] deep pantses
you [ __ ] [ __ ] d-pants you guys
one more time
i think you guys should have to rename
your city to something else like they
should just lay the name buffalo
i don't know something you guys have to
burn sage i don't know what it's gonna
be i'm just [ __ ] with you
congratulations um
that's the game if i was um
uh uh uh eddie fatface whatever the
[ __ ] commissioner's name is if i was
that guy and i wanted ratings that's the
[ __ ] game i would want i would want
tampa bay versus the buffalo bills
and
uh buffalo bill fans i swear to god if
you guys get into the super bowl do
yourself a favor do not turn on espn
during the two weeks of super bowl hype
if there is two weeks i don't know if
there is anyone at the end of next week
because all it is gonna be is about
those four [ __ ] super bowl losses
you know and all of that blah blah blah
blah and then they're gonna do oh
it's gonna be nauseating
as they make you guys out to be joe
six-pack and all these great [ __ ]
people
and you're not
you're not bad people but you're no
better than anyone else just because you
haven't won a super bowl
[Music]
i [ __ ] hate when they do that
you know they they show up every year
they're just great fans and they just
everybody does everybody shows up year
after year what else are we gonna do
all right
we're the peasants
we can't invent things
we're not smart
we go down to the coliseum ah throw them
to the lions that's what we do
we go to a ufc event
and the second it goes to the ground for
longer than 15 seconds we start booing
we're morons
[Music]
of course we're going to keep showing up
um anyway
so um
plowing ahead here uh i missed a lot of
the uh the play i watched the patriots
game i really didn't watch anything else
um
i went out and i flew today i'm in
pre-production on this project that i uh
was lucky enough to get going
so my days are jam-packed and if i don't
i have to fly so i don't forget how to
fly so today i flew up from los angeles
all the way up to bikersfield
and uh there's a couple airports up
there and uncontrolled and a controlled
meaning one doesn't have a tower and
yeah i want that
so uh i went to the uncontrolled they
got fuel there and uh
you know
deliberately went up there light just
because uh
i'm trying to you know there's there's
always a little tricky thing when you
this one's got this weird thing where
like you you go you stick your gas card
in and then it [ __ ] asks you what
your password is and i thought it was
for my credit card and i was getting it
wrong for like 10 minutes but they're
like printing a slip and you got to take
the slip and then read the password i
don't know what the [ __ ] it's
so anyways but it was fun and we ended
up going um
you know over to the controlled one and
then we flew
out to the east and there was a couple
of uncontrolled ones and they had like
these glider
airplanes out there this really great
little restaurant called the raven or
something like that raven's nest
and um
i was just watching these planes like
towing these gliders out there and it's
just like
i was talking to my instructor going
those have to be like some of the best
like
pilots out there as far as like uh
if they're ever in a cessna and there's
an engine failure
you know
i don't think they're that nerd the only
thing i would think is is that those
gliders can glide a lot longer and
farther so they got to like
take that into consideration but like
it's every single landing
that they do
is essentially an engine failure it's
really [ __ ] amazing
so we were watching these planes like
tow em out and stuff and um
yeah it was it was amazing and uh
it was really windy when we were up
there we were heavy we had fuel we had
two people in there and uh
everything was good and then you know i
went to go off the little uh the taxiway
and i made a left i just got spun around
by the wind the low rpm horn came i was
like what the [ __ ]
um so i learned something there
you know
did the dumb thing as i started going
down the ground i started pulling the
collective up instead of putting it down
so it got a little hairy there for a
second but then i was i was able to kind
of like figure it out
um
with the help of my instructor whatever
but i never fly at that altitude so i
was just like all right so i and i
learned a whole bunch of [ __ ] just in
those couple of seconds so um that also
was flying and by the way none of it was
i mean it was like literally like you
know i'm like a foot off the ground so
it wasn't anything crazy
um
it's just one of those little squirrely
things that can happen
if uh
if you're at a high altitude with a lot
and you're heavy
um
so anyway um
i uh
just kind of flew all around out there
kind of liking flying up there i've kind
of flown over la for like for six seven
years and i'm bored with it and then you
get out there in the desert and it's
amazing and there's like nobody out
there
and then also if you ever had a problem
you can [ __ ] put it anywhere as
opposed to like
when you're in la where there's all
kinds of like wires and [ __ ] all
kinds of other [ __ ]
houses people that type of stuff so
anyway i uh been doing that working out
trying to get in shape man um by the
time you hear this i will be in new york
city
uh we are doing the ninth
sort of annual you know with this
[ __ ] covered [ __ ] uh we had to miss a
year so the 9th annual 10th year
since we've been doing it for the 9th
annual annual patrice o'neill comedy
benefit
um i got a whole bunch of new [ __ ] i
went out did like 20 25 minutes
the other night uh here in la
and i just had the best time just like
not doing anything for my that i did at
red rocks having a [ __ ] great time um
ran to a buddy of mine i hadn't seen a
long time
shooting this [ __ ] with him got all
caught up so uh i'm looking forward to
um doing all the new [ __ ] and seeing how
that works back east
and uh and also somehow trying to go
into new york city and not getting
covered um that [ __ ] is getting like
beyond beyond contagious
um but i'm just gonna keep doing what uh
i've been told to do and i don't know
it just seems to be working
[Laughter]
dude you know what i think you should do
why don't you just do what the smarter
people say to them dude they're not that
smart
i have the internet okay
um
i was talking to somebody the other day
who had gotten it the second time and
got over it and was saying like i need
to go to the doctor there's not
something i'm not breathing right
there's something wrong with me and i'm
just like
yeah
okay now hey man
it's you was that the third amendment i
can breathe in a virus if i want to all
right do it have fun with that
you do that you enjoy that me i'm opting
out
um
absolutely [ __ ] opting out on that
[ __ ] so
anyway why can't i get [ __ ]
comfortable here
you know why bill because you've never
done a studio that's why if at some
point you ever did a studio
it's so stupid you know what i'm like
you've been walking one of those [ __ ]
restaurants
and these are a pet peeve of mine you
know like you go to a place like oh my
god dude they have the best salami
sandwich
there's an old guy he's been doing it
the same [ __ ] way for the last 30
years and you show up and it takes like
90 minutes to just order i swear to god
i will walk across the street to a
[ __ ] mcdonald's
before i do that you know
that is i i swear to god i've done that
so many [ __ ] times i'll see something
on the internet everybody says it's the
spot and i walk and the second i see the
line
i just i go [ __ ] this and i i go into a
wendy's
[Music]
and i'm not gonna lie to you when i'm in
the wendy's i'm cursing my brains out
you know
[ __ ] goddamn stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
sucking [ __ ] internet blowing up
every good [ __ ] spot out there
flipping out meanwhile it's like
i wouldn't have known about the spot if
it wasn't for covid
sorry covert the internet sorry i was
looking at the word covert here
if it wasn't for covet i wouldn't know
where to eat
um
anyway uh speaking of that oh my god
dude my son
flipped out was so [ __ ] mad at me i
actually felt bad
he was so goddamn he has this thing man
where he just like he doesn't want to
sit in his chair and eat
he wants to walk around
and he wants to do the whole thing
you know he doesn't quite know how to
use a fork he just wants to use it and
flick [ __ ] around
and it's just like all right
that's what you want to do buddy
but then he had like this little bowl of
bolognese right
and he somehow got it you know i looked
the other way and he got in his [ __ ]
hands
and i was trying to take it away from
him because i knew he was going to drop
it it was going to be this big mess
and the second i want to take it away
he's so strong his little cute hands
just gripped the ball and he went like
he's yelling i'm like nobody no i just
have to take this and like
his whole head turned red
and pulled away
and then i let go and then he was
looking at me and then i was like i just
i have to get this away from you
i just have because you're gonna you
know it's gonna go all over the rug all
over the floor it's gonna be a nightmare
so i went in and i just had to overpower
him to get it away from him
and he he screamed as loud as he's ever
screamed put his face down into the bowl
did like a 300 yell except with like a
baby voice
he was so
and [ __ ] mad at me and i got it away
from him
and then he just ran at me
and just threw his [ __ ] arms all the
way up
like a [ __ ] gorilla at the zoo like
he was just gonna beat my ass and he
came flying into my legs i'm just like
oh my god
and i put it down i was just going i'm
sorry buddy i'm sorry he was so
[ __ ] upset
it was just it was awful like it like
ruined for like two hours of the day
that i made him that mad
um even though you know i was doing the
right thing i mean i [ __ ] up as a dad
that he got a bowl of bolognese in his
hands what the [ __ ] was i thinking i
wasn't
but he got so goddamn mad at me
and um
yeah it really [ __ ] broke my heart
for like two hours because i know what a
big deal that is that's his world you
know
i you know he gets a really a good
feeling of satisfaction doing things for
himself
and i took that
away from him
and he doesn't understand that it was
for his own good
oh man
i was just thinking like is this what
like
that was a scary thing because i'm just
thinking like okay now just multiply
this times 10 years and all of that type
of stuff when you know it's something
else or whatever but
i still think i'm going to be all right
you know
as far as being like a parent and stuff
like that and i never listened to
you know all the parents well you went
you wait [ __ ] 10 years it's like
maybe you [ __ ] up
you know why just because your kid is
acting like
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't know
i know that there's gonna be times when
you know they're gonna be like oh my god
dad shut up or whatever i i get that
this can be times like that but i i just
don't want to have like the uh
the like resentment
and that type of [ __ ] but i think that
that comes from not listening to your
kids and telling them to shut the [ __ ]
up
uh like the way it was done when i was
growing up you know what i mean so um
yeah and i'll tell you the the [ __ ]
side effects of that do you guys know to
this [ __ ] day
to this day
when things are not working out for me i
get [ __ ] pissed
rather
than just communicating to people how i
need things to be done and my wife is
helping me out with that and i realized
that i never did that because when i was
a kid
like no kid could do that you couldn't
be like
hey you know can i actually it's it's
like
parents back then were just like hey
snap the fingers shut the [ __ ] up or
whatever so you just kind of felt like
you had no options and i kind of carried
that into my adult life
like i'm i'm literally talking about
like
getting going to a restaurant getting a
completely different order and then just
not [ __ ] saying anything because
i just i'm doing the formula of a kid
like oh if i say something else then i'm
going to get yelled at so i'll just
[ __ ] sit here and eat this thing that
i don't want
or uh
you know even because my wife would be
suggesting something like hey
i you know
what do you want to do on sunday like
this moment i would immediately think
it's [ __ ] playoff football i want to
[ __ ]
and then i'd rather than just saying
that
that the playoffs are on i want to watch
playoff football
um i would just oh that's a dumb example
because i was never at a point
emotionally where i wouldn't say that it
was player football
you know
i wasn't that [ __ ] up
it's just like are you out of your mind
do you want to go do something to me
when when andy cohen is doing the
wrap-up of one of those real housewives
shows i know you don't
all right
and i'm aware that we both don't know
each other's tv schedules you have no
idea when the nfl playoffs are on and i
have no idea when he's wrapping up one
of those seasons but if you tell me that
that's what you're watching i get it
it's important oh [ __ ] you know what
we're watching we're watching this
[ __ ] show
i can't even believe it's real it's this
true [ __ ] crime they're like
there's this [ __ ] family like in
south carolina where like three
generations of them
are uh
were like basically the d.a
of this small town and they knew all the
cops
and they just had all of this [ __ ]
power
and then they have this [ __ ] kid
this little bastard for you know not
raised right
he goes out he boozes on a boat
everyone's telling him not to drive he
hits a [ __ ] bridge
this girl gets killed
no charges are brought against him and
then they gotta [ __ ] sue the family
and then and then
and when i fell asleep last night there
was some openly gay kid
that got killed they tried to make it
look like a hit-and-run it was [ __ ]
bananas this story was [ __ ] bananas
it reminded me of that show
i forget the name of it it took place in
florida
i want to say it was a netflix show had
norbert leo butts in it um
oh what was that it was just a [ __ ]
incredible show and then for some reason
they just
they didn't renew it or whatever um
it was literally that family except it
was real and it was in rather than
florida it was in south carolina
um i'm going to try to find the name of
it if you guys can see this [ __ ]
story
um
your wife yeah we're just exhausted
because you know we
we're hanging with the kids having a
blast we went out like [ __ ]
uh
playing like miniature golf and [ __ ]
and dude it's just like real golf in
that
there's always some people like
in front of you playing too slow that
suck
or there's people behind you that are
better than you and you're stressing out
because they're [ __ ] getting it
through the windmill and they're sitting
on the you know waiting the tee off
um
and then there's just all these people
like taking it seriously it's like
there's a f there's a [ __ ]
this looks like dr seuss designed this
thing what are you doing just [ __ ]
hit the ball who gives a [ __ ]
they're keeping score and stuff
just like what the [ __ ] are you doing so
i didn't give a [ __ ]
and my wife was just crushing it she
just like parred the first three holes i
bogeyed all of them
and then like the reverse happened where
it's funny like my daughter is so much
like my wife where they both
stopped giving a [ __ ] on like the 12th
hole
they were both bored like my wife didn't
give a [ __ ] anymore my daughter's
climbing on [ __ ] rocks
and at that point like i'm trying to now
now i give a [ __ ] i'm trying to par
every hole
um
yeah we had a good time
went to the arcade we just did just
total [ __ ] white trash off afternoon
it was fantastic
and then we went out to this this uh old
school diner
and uh just got some [ __ ] malted
milkshakes or whatever
um
but anyways what the [ __ ] was i talking
about i don't even i don't even know
what the hell was talking about
what the hell was it i don't know who
knows anyway um
let's uh let's do some of the reads here
for the week
by the way uh all right bet mgm
bet mgm has arrived in new york oh my
god five boroughs of degenerates right
is it five
brooklyn queens bronx manhattan staten
island oh my god talk about sports
betting in new york and how big a deal
it is
it's a huge deal
it's a huge deal because new york city
looks down in new jersey
they think that they're better than them
and the last thing they want to do is to
go in and have to drive through the
whole [ __ ] state to go down to
atlantic city
to try and go to the trump whatever
before it goes out of business again
um if you're in the state of new york or
any other state state where bet mgm is
is live sign up using bonus code bur
b-u-r-r and you get 200 dollars free
after placing your first 10 dollar bet
regardless of the outcome here's how it
works download the bet mgm app and sign
up using bonus code bur burr place your
first 10 bet on any event you receive
200 in free bets right after you place
your first bet talk about how you and
paul have been working with bet mgm all
season making pits and who you like for
the rest of the playoffs
oh well i would have done that anyways
so me and paul version have been working
with bet mgm all season making picks um
and actually both of us
on the anything better podcast we both
picked four games a week
and bet against the spread and both of
us were like four or five games over 500
after betting like 72 games against the
spread i mean come on
who the [ __ ] am i
um who do i like in the rest of the
playoffs with my picks this week in the
playoffs i think i've lost every bet so
far except kc but i was teasing them so
i think um
like i teased the patriots to get more
points that obviously didn't work that
[ __ ] that bet over i teased the eagles
to get more points that didn't [ __ ]
work i teased the cowboys down
i don't think that worked because they
lost by six
and
uh who else did i take
and then i had
kc i teased kc down i believe so uh who
do i like let me just see who i like
um
i think the super bowl winner is coming
out of the nfc
um and it's obviously either aaron
rodgers
or tom brady and i just i have a feeling
it's just gonna be tom brady again
i just think that that guy
gets dialed in
and he has such credibility
because he is the greatest of all time
it doesn't make any sense
the man is is is sliding into 50.
he's in his george blanda years he looks
younger at 44 than he did at 34. he has
a quicker release
i i just i mean i don't know
i don't i'll tell you the team that i
think can [ __ ] knock somebody off i
don't know if they played yet this year
is the titans are they playing are they
playing tomorrow night like the titans
is not a team that i would want to be
playing
i don't know why if that henry guy comes
back and he's like 80 85 i don't [ __ ]
like that at all
um so anyway disclaimer all states must
read
all right visit betmgm.com for terms and
condition 21 years of age or older to
wager
uh in arizona colorado d.c
iowa indiana louisiana
michigan missouri new jersey nevada new
york pennsylvania tennessee virginia
west virginia wyoming and washington
only i did that with abbreviations with
state abbreviations thank you very much
all promotions are subject to
qualifications and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets
or site credit
free bets expire in seven days from
issuance excludes michigan disassociated
persons please gamble responsibly
gambling problem call 1-800 next step in
arizona 1-800-522-4700
in colorado d.c i'm not reading all of
this [ __ ] one eight hundred two in
colorado dc
louisiana nevada wyoming virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
in michigan 1-800 gambler
indiana new jersey pennsylvania and uh
west virginia
i'm not reading all of this
if you have a gambling problem there's a
1-800 or 188 number
in your area all right have fun with
this [ __ ] that's what me and paul versi
did you have fun gambling
have fun with it don't lose your house
don't lose your marriage don't lose your
kids college education have a good
[ __ ] time all right
whatever just whatever the [ __ ] it is
that you would have gone and blown at
sea world not sea world why would you do
that every weekend that'd be too much
money you know what i mean you know what
your [ __ ] budget is
all right pick a game put some money on
it
and have a good time that's it all right
but don't be a [ __ ] idiot okay
whether it's finding a signature color
wearing or a more flattering cut or
getting a new statement a new statement
piece
i'm making a statement the right detail
can take your wardrobe up a notch this
year let indochino take care of your
2022 style edit uh you can customize
everything from suits and shirts to
chinos and bomber jackets at prices more
affordable than you might expect and
nochino offers completely custom fitted
suits shirts casual wear and more at
surprisingly affordable prices get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune
everyone every piece is made to your
exact measurements
excuse me
and you can
sorry about that every piece has made
your exact measurements and you can
customize every detail i had a little
pizza tonight sorry choose everything
about your suit including the fabric
lapel monogram and statement linings you
can create a suit that fits you and your
style perfectly the best part indochino
suits start at just 429 it starts from
79 with all custom customizations
included give yourself a style edit that
sets the tone for the rest of the year
with indochino
um get 50 off any purchase of 3.99 or
more by using the promo code burr at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 3.99 or more at i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com promo code burr indochino
all right solo
stove
all right are you a loner do you like to
cook here we go solo stove there's
nothing quite like the feeling of
gathering around a warm fire on a cool
evening and a smokeless fire pit from
solo stove makes your outdoor moments
even more memorable because instead of
having to constantly dodge campfire
fumes you can sit back and relax and
actually enjoy the fire and right now
you can get a great deal on solos on a
solo stove fire pit upgrade your
backyard with the solo stove fire pit
it's the perfect catalyst for getting
outside and spending more time with
family and friends solo stove fire
prints pits are brilliantly engineered
it's great for s'mores
made with premium grade 304 stainless
steel and a 360 degree airflow system
that maximizes efficiency while
minimizing smoke
easy to light with a few bits of starter
your fire is blazing in minutes
perfectly portable take solo stove with
you on camping trips and more shop now
and get up to 30 off fire pits all month
long and use promo code burr at checkout
to get an extra 10 off plus a lifetime
warranty and free 30-day returns just go
to solostove.com and remember you get 10
off when you use promo code burr
all right is this the last one
yes it is oh look who it is everybody
it's all birds
all birds everyone you know even though
it will be wet and chilly in most parts
of the country running will still be a
part of people's lives trying to achieve
their personal best um you always got to
have respect for those people running
out in the [ __ ] rain
the wool dasher mizzle
our weather repellent performance
running shoe is the first shoe of its
kind no more soggy feet that's amazing
it's sustainably made from natural
materials with a low environmental
impact on the planet but you got goals
to meet and miles to log keep your feet
warm and dry with the weather repellent
wool dasher mizzle shoe from all birds
all birds printed the wool dasher
missile carbon footprint right on the
shoe so you know its impact on the
planet
oh you know how much it it impacts the
plan okay then they offset the footprint
to zero
uh to make it a carbon neutral product
they offset the footprint okay
all right because we're not talking
about the sneaker or your foot you're
talking about a carbon footprint jesus
christ all birds built the wool dasher
missile using natural materials to have
a low environmental impact so you can
break a sweat without breaking the
planet by the way people wrote this copy
the copy is fine i'm just stupid
please don't send those poor people back
to the [ __ ] writer's room and if
you're going to can you can you up their
per diem for lunch uh this winter keep
our feet cozy and dry keep your feet
cozy and dry with all birds one word
wool dasher missiles m-i-z-z-l-e-s
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-r-d-s.com oh yeah
all right that's it for the reads okay
all right let's let's let's see what you
guys had to say this week
all right
okay look at apple watch hey billy
crimson crotch
[Music]
even though that's recycled i've heard
that one before i still love that one
um
first of all avid listener to the
podcast and i loved efforts for family
well look at you
aren't you just a salt of the earth son
of a [ __ ] god bless you
god bless you um last monday you asked
why the apple watch is not called the
iwatch
a company by the name of om
gel electronics omg electronics oh oh my
god electronics
uh got a trademark on the name in 2012
before apple did
probably in hopes of getting money from
apple when they inevitably
followed the ipad imac and iphone with
the iwatch
so apple avoided that all together and
called it the apple watch
ah
isn't that nice
i feel bad for the people at omg
electronics
it would have been nice if they threw
him a little bit of cash keep up the
good work and come back to l.a saw you
in long beach and you killed
um
yeah you know i [ __ ] root for people
like that you know if you're going to do
some [ __ ] like that you anticipate it
you can't get mad at that you know
like that [ __ ] guy
we uh
remember that guy who
he cornered the market on hand sanitizer
right before the pandemic
i mean the guy was one of the great
calls of all time how many times have
they told us something's coming
sars and all of this [ __ ] y2k it never
[ __ ] happens this guy's like i think
this one's real
i got a feeling in my gut i'm gonna fill
up my garage with [ __ ] hand
sanitizers and that's what the guy does
and he gets vilified
for price gouging [ __ ] hand sanitizer
and all of this [ __ ] right
and then meanwhile all the corporations
can do it and nobody gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] gas is like on its way to being
six dollars a goddamn gallon nobody even
used it last year you should have a
whole bunch of extra
or whatever two years ago in 2020 nobody
even [ __ ] used this [ __ ]
all of this is just [ __ ] emotion i
don't have any goddamn facts behind this
[ __ ]
um all right if i were a dictator oh
this is my one of my favorite things and
you guys are really responding to this
it's a fun thing
to fantasize about being a dictator
isn't it
i [ __ ] enjoy it
i really [ __ ] enjoy it um
if i were a dictator if you weren't a
doctor and you were questioning doctors
the next time you needed surgery i'd
make you perform it on yourself
um if i were a dictator uh hi bill if i
was a dictator i will make it illegal
for 14 year olds and below to own a
smartphone thank
you thank you
i don't understand that on any [ __ ]
level
the [ __ ] that is out there on the
[ __ ] internet
and this [ __ ] that oh you can put on
the parental [ __ ] blocks on it and
they can literally google how to turn
them off or some [ __ ] nerd
will figure out how to do it at school
it's so [ __ ] dumb
like
um
i can't imagine the fallout
these [ __ ] kids they don't even they
don't even get a childhood
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that you can see on the
goddamn internet and you just hand your
kid a phone
i'm not i'm not doing that [ __ ] my kid's
gonna get a [ __ ] flip phone that's
where they my kids are gonna hate me but
it's just like trust me i'm doing you a
favor but then with their their friends
will just show the videos
it's really bad man
we're so [ __ ] far behind with that
[ __ ] about protecting kids
with the internet and and phones and all
of that type of stuff
i don't know maybe that's part of the
conspiracy maybe they're doing that and
they'll be like hey man
a microchip doesn't have any porn on it
um
canadian dictator
dear pencil dictator
first and foremost i'm sorry for your
loss
uh your anecdote about the comic
leech that ended with bob's one-liner
about stealing the eggs
uh hit hard
oh yeah man that was one of the funny
that was one of the great ones i can
tell you love the guy and i'm glad he
knew how you felt yeah man thank you
yeah man that was um
i don't know
that was one of the [ __ ]
i can't even tell you one of the most
brutal weeks and inspiring weeks
um
[Music]
with bob sackett passing which i still
cannot believe is real i just cannot
[ __ ] believe that that guy is gone
and uh of all the friends that i've lost
i don't think i've laughed more
thinking about a friend
than that guy and i swear to god like i
it's this is like his passing has been
like inspirational
like he even him dying was inspiring
just how
like everybody from all different areas
of his life all said the same thing
about what a great guy he was and how
[ __ ] hilarious he was
um yeah man i love talking about the guy
too he just he's he was i swear to god
man just
everything that everybody's saying is
true all right anyway secondly as a
non-american
let me tell you all the [ __ ] that is
wrong with your goddamn mess of a
country
i know how much you love that huh just
[ __ ] with you um if i was a dictator
of the us because canada is clearly
flawless
why can't no no dude you got to write
back and do one for canada i want to
know what's going on up there because
you got a lot of [ __ ] people up there
saying this is the end of our democracy
and all that i follow some of you
canadians
and i oh why don't you stick to [ __ ]
writing kids book you got the same
[ __ ] thing going on up there anyway
here's how i build a utopia a i'd widen
the pay gap between minimum wage and
high skilled jobs but i would offer free
college slash skilled labor training for
anyone who wanted to live better no
living wage for getting high and
flipping burgers for 40 years
um teacher would teachers would get paid
i like that one teachers would get paid
as much as engineers not because they
are angels or something uh simply to
grow the
the pool of high quality teachers so
every community could get
get equal education every kid in the
country would start life well educated
enroll into free college slash skills
training resulting and constantly
growing tax base this would also
brainwash the next generation to accept
the benefits of my rule um have you guys
watched that
yet youtube video i forget the name of
it that it shows
why uh dictators are so brutal to the
people and how they have to keep the
military happy this is what's missing
because this is all us peasants saying
how how we would hook each other up and
then get rid of the piece of [ __ ]
peasants but nobody is is dealing with
how are you going to hang on to your
throne
anyway i would force health care
providers and drug manufacturers to
negotiate rates directly with me for the
entire nation
you just put a big bull's-eye on your
back uh the provider who offers the best
health care for the lowest cost gets the
contract
um if service quality declines
management is exiled and negotiations
open back up
all right well how do you prevent some
other wannabe dictator
from um
giving a better deal
to those healthcare providers and then
they start backing you then you're in
trouble
but i like all these ideas it seems like
you're working for the people here
finally i watch owners would have to
complete an annual three-day solo hike
through grizzly bear territory it's a
surefire way to thin the herd i even
keep the iwatch commercials on tv long
long after just to catch any stragglers
we don't need in the dna dna pool
all right i like all of that
all right dictator
uh good morning captain drizzle dick
thanks for reading this you asked about
dictator dictator dictation
i'd be the imperial grammar dictator oh
god
meaning i create an empire of
well-spoken citizens through
dictatorship mispronounced [ __ ] up
grammar such as the following would be
punishable by my grammar police
irregardless
it's regardless you stupid [ __ ] sticks i
like that you're still profane
as as a uh a grammar police person its
meaning is without regard
kind of like you're [ __ ] up grammar
um
well you're the you also say stupid [ __ ]
sticks so let's not [ __ ] make you
shakespeare over here expresso
there is not one single x
in the word
espresso
or especially for that matter
what do i say i think i say espresso
don't i although you wrote expresso so i
said expresso
can i get espresso can i get an espresso
i think i say express i think i think i
say with x
like uh i learned a long time ago it's
uh
etc is
is that you say it with or etc i forget
i was never good at this [ __ ] uh
confusing singular with plural
is there any more of them
you californians are horrible with this
is equals singular are equals plural
is there any more of them are there any
more of them oh jesus christ
dude oh my god i feel bad for the woman
in your life uh holistic
another cali special [ __ ] overused
crap word
all right i'll go with this one it is
indeed a word but it doesn't make you
sound hip cool or smart it makes you
sound like a [ __ ] douchebag
um it just makes me sound like i'm gonna
[ __ ] pay extra money for something
that shouldn't be you know probably
should be 25 cheaper and there's no way
for me to prove
if this thing is uh is actually going to
do what it says
um it started life artisan ice cream
just go across the street into a [ __ ]
you know pharmacy
and buy the same ice cream that the
people who are like 80 years old have
been eating it their whole life they're
still alive
um all right first offense a written
warning second a hundred dollar fine
third mandatory eight hour grammar class
four you are shipped to a continent a
containment camp on the east side of the
salton sea until deemed fit to re-enter
our well-spoken dictatorship well look
at you you know you're really into
grammar
you know you're not into violence
i don't know
there'd be a bunch of people dude i
don't [ __ ] care i'm out here [ __ ]
son
they're feeding us right
hey is there any more than miller lights
um all right if i were a dictator hey
bill
if i were a dictator the first thing i
would do is set a daily limit to the
number of words each person can say
wow
if anyone speaks more than they are
allowed they will be drone struck
okay now here's somebody ruling with an
iron fist next anyone with a longer dick
than me will be killed immediately
unfortunately that's going to be a lot
of people
but what about all the guys that have
the same size dick issue
you know if you want to be the jon
holmes with a five incher you got to
kill everybody down to four inches
um next all guys will have to work uh as
banker [ __ ] lawyers or politician they
can opt out of these jobs but the only
other option will be a make-up person at
macy's all women will have to work at
labor-intensive jobs such as
construction or mining
wow
is there any i want to know the reasons
for this this is wild
next
the nets and the lakers will get
unlimited budgets
and will be the only teams allowed to
use steroids the federal reserve will be
allowed to print as much money as it
likes there will be no health care for
anyone
i will make sure global warming
continues until the whole world has
summer year round i can't wait to take
my yacht through times square in january
lastly i will divide the country into
two halves i will split all the trump
voters and hillary voters the trump
voters will have
hillary as their president and the
hillary voters will have trump as their
president after 10 years if everyone
learns to behave themselves i will step
down as dictator and assign tom brady to
be president
you know something i think we have a
winner here that was the most clear and
concise plan
and i felt that he was or she was ruling
with enough of an iron fist that they
could maintain their power
all right
uh congress
members unsurprisingly are surprisingly
good at picking stocks and they had on
in parentheses hey oh billy banker
you're always talking about the
corruption of both the blue ties and the
red ties so i thought you'd find this
article interesting it analyzes the 2021
stock market trades of members of
congress and surprise surprise they do
pretty well in fact in 2021 they beat
the market if you really want to get
heated you can read the full article
oh jesus i mean well yeah well they're
grossly underpaid they're grossly
underpaid so they're susceptible to
corruption bribery and all of that
um
that's [ __ ] hilarious it's just so
[ __ ]
yeah and everybody there's like a
[ __ ] millionaire
what do you make as a congressman it's
like 125 150 a year
say what they make president or like 200
250 or something yeah they're not going
to sit around taking all that [ __ ]
you know and once every i don't know how
long you know a bunch of people from a
dave and busters are going to storm
through there and kill some people on
january 6th without making a little
money
all right here are just a few
interesting facts
from the report
hundreds of millions of dollars have
been exchanged in the stock market by
our elected officials in 2021 alone
in just equit equities congress bought
and sold nearly 290 million throughout
the year
these are people that make 250 grand a
year hang on a second
all right
how much
do
senators make a year
um
senators in the house representative
make 174 000 a year
and collectively
they sold nearly 200 90 million in
stocks last year
[Laughter]
they've been doing that forever he
though he did really well she did really
well in the private sector oh
did she in 2021 the congress beat the
market this report shows which
sectors were preferred by each party and
branch oftentimes huge trades amount
could be attributed to one or two
members
big legislation so they're not all
corrupt there's a couple of people oh
god big legislative events such as the
infrastructure bill getting passed by
the senate were often preceded by
politicians trading in the sectors
affected
i mean that's not insider trading there
were tons of they probably just give
stock tips to the [ __ ] [ __ ] on wall
street and i don't know
who police it and they just let them get
away with it there were tons of unusual
trades where politicians made millions
of dollars
yeah
and they won't get any [ __ ] [ __ ] for
it
and that is why that they just i don't
know
once again like i said they go after uh
yeah like
we go after comedians and [ __ ] what we
need to do is we need to just we need to
get on the inside of the stock market or
something
be able to make some of these [ __ ] some
money
and then they'll stop [ __ ] with us i
guess although i kind of feel like they
have doesn't it feel like it's kind of
over
all of that canceled culture [ __ ] i just
feel like it's just it kind of just died
you know
people who didn't really deserve to get
canceled or back
you know
people who should have been you know
to have a time out or whatever are
allowed to kind of put their lives back
together which always made sense to me
you know every day there's people who
get paroled out of prison who did way
worse than most of the people that got
in trouble not saying all but most of
them
so if they can try to put their [ __ ]
lives back together
you know
i mean you know why can't other people i
don't i don't get it i don't give a [ __ ]
why do i comment on these things i have
no idea i can tell you right now i am so
[ __ ] dehydrated right now
you know i keep doing the goddamn
elliptical
can you hear all this [ __ ] noise that
i'm hearing me undoing these wires here
um i keep doing the [ __ ] elliptical
like every goddamn day
i've been doing yoga i've been doing all
of this [ __ ] i've been dropping weight
you wouldn't know by what i said i eat
eight this week but every other than
that i eat [ __ ] perfectly
but i've been dropping weight uh i look
good i feel good but i'm [ __ ]
dehydrated as [ __ ]
because uh
i don't know i don't like drinking water
when i'm doing the elliptical
because you have to like slow down no
matter how much you slow down it
dribbles down your [ __ ] chin and i
got to keep my stupid mask on
you know
there's this one person at my gym they
don't know that i know but i know
they [ __ ] put their mask on and what
they do is they double fold it
and they they lift it up over their
mouth
and then they have it hanging down and
then they're bringing you can totally
see it from the side
[Laughter]
i call the person the cheater
um
but whatever
the [ __ ] you gonna do so anyway um i'm
gonna close this out by once again
uh congratulations to the bills you guys
are looking like [ __ ] world beaters
uh i am rooting for tom brady and the
buccaneers of course
but my uh my second team is the bills
you know
i mean i just you know
i i don't know why i just want to see
brady get another one
[ __ ] have eight
you know be amazing then he gets eight
and then then he can go for three in a
row which nobody's ever done
um
yeah it'd be fantastic because i just
like oh my god i'm so [ __ ] sick of
him i'm not why are you sick of the
scene that you you know
i wonder if people back in the 1920s
were like oh my god i'm so sick of babe
ruth
we get it you're the greatest [ __ ]
baseball player were they sick of them
you know there were people i don't want
to go down there and see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they didn't go to yankee
stadium or they didn't go to their local
ballpark to see babe [ __ ] roof why
wouldn't you do that
um
i don't know you can't be like that
if somebody's [ __ ] great you gotta
give it up and you gotta root for them
to be the the greatest ever so you could
say that you sought
i would think i don't know
uh speaking of which i've just become
obsessed
with the cincinnati bengals
um their whole thing in the 1970s
where you know they came out in like 68
and they had paul brown
and bill walsh
and that kid greg cook you gotta see the
story on this kid this kid was like
bill walsh said he was the greatest
quarterback
talent he ever coached
including you know joe montana
and um
you know guy blew out his rotator cuff
they didn't know what happened and they
didn't know how to fix him back then and
it just you know made his arm weak and
it just ended his [ __ ] career and he
got really had a sad life after that
um
but then his backup had a weaker arm and
that's when bill walsh
created the west coast offense
in cincinnati
and it was called the west coast offense
not until 1985 i guess when bill
parcells giants beat the 49ers
and bill parcells said hey how do you
like that west coast offense now and
then that's what and that coined the
phrase but it was actually created and
they had a guy isaac curtis did i talk
about this was version or did i already
talk about this on the podcast i
remember they had a guy isaac curtis he
was the fastest guy in the nfl and he is
the reason the isaac curtis rule is that
after five yards you can't interfere
with the player because paul brown said
what is the point of having a performer
if they're not allowed to perform
they [ __ ] went jumping on them and
[ __ ] the whole way down the field so
that's the reason for that
the mel blunt rule
is when he beat the [ __ ] out of golden
richards in the super bowl in 1976 he
was literally just beating him up
um like punching him in the head and
[ __ ] was [ __ ] nuts so they're like
you can't do that
um
but wait they're kind of the same rule
though
i could look those up try to find the
the nuance between the the isaac curtis
rule
and the uh the mel blunt rule
um
and i also i'm a big fan of rules named
after players
like sean avery
you can't turn around and face the
goalie
and just stick your hand in front of his
eyes or whatever i just loved
that there wasn't a rule that said
you couldn't do that and nobody thought
to do it until he did it and then just
the [ __ ] balls that that took
because he has his back to the shooter
and there's no there's no padding
even if there's [ __ ] he just getting
hit in the [ __ ] foot would kill at a
pickup rink
forget about it get hit in the calf by
an nhl slap shot from the [ __ ] point
and he didn't get he was so about
winning he didn't give a [ __ ]
turned around just stuck his hand there
that was hilarious so
um anyway that guy should have a podcast
that guy is [ __ ] hilarious
uh but if he does have a podcast please
send it my way i want to i want to uh
i want to listen to that um anyway all
right that's the podcast for this week
all dehydrated bill congratulations to
the bills i got to tell you something
man that interception was one of the
greatest interceptions i've seen in a
long
long [ __ ] time you guys you guys got
a great coach they got somebody up in
the booth that used to work with
belichick and nick saban i mean these
guys they are built to win this whole
[ __ ] thing
and i gotta tell you man i think they
got a better vibe
than those great buffalo teams
um
of the late 80s early 90s i think this
one just seems more
uh they got that cold-blooded serial
killer [ __ ] thing that you have to
have as a champion so uh
i don't know man i think that they uh i
think that they it's gonna come down i'm
just obvious [ __ ] it goes down to casey
and the bills
unless casey completely [ __ ] it up and
the steelers beat him while i'm doing
the podcast here it comes down to kc and
the bills
and i think the bills could beat him
absolutely beat him and you know i was
watching tonight
and
you know kansas city gets down to the
goal line
and they do a little razzle dazzle and
then
patrick mahone's literally underhands
the ball to somebody
like he would throw to a three-year-old
and everybody's oh my god
it's like the [ __ ] globetrotters i
love collinsworth he's like it's like
the globetrotters it's like is it that
looks like me trying to teach my
daughter how to catch
i was joking on twitter that like when
he threw that when josh allen threw that
ball sidearm if patrick mahomes did that
the announcers would have talked about
it for the rest of the game i mean it is
just odd look at the angle of his arm i
mean that is fun you would think that
nobody ever slinged its sidearm before
the guy i will give it up i never saw
somebody throw a no-look pass
i will give that up but um
i don't know there's just something
about when he does [ __ ] like that
they act like they've never seen it
before i mean what i'm seeing there was
that's just the holy roller turned into
a [ __ ] forward lateral ken stabler
did that [ __ ] 40 years ago oh bill
you're really gonna be an angry old man
yes i am yes i am all right that's the
podcast